Thank You Nicholas for the inspiring
talk I'm Skylar Tibbits I'm faculty in
the department of architecture and I'm
going to introduce the programmable
session so as we just heard Nikolas
Nikolas predicted that in 1995 the world
would be digital and that obviously has
come true and he predicted many things
that have have come from that but I
would argue the world has become more
and more material in it and I'm going to
try to show you what I mean by that so
this is the first CAD tool Sutherland
sketchpad invented here at MIT that has
its contemporary counterparts in
sophisticated software and simulation
that have radically changed nearly every
discipline whether that's design
mathematics computer science biology
earth and planetary science software and
digital technologies have radically
changed the way we think they radically
change the way we design what we can
imagine what we can optimize evaluate
and ultimately what we can build this is
the first CNC machine also invented here
at MIT in roughly the same time the
first time a computer was connected to a
milling machine and that obviously has
its contemporary counterparts in digital
fabrication if you look at just one of
those sectors if you look at 3d printing
there's nearly everyday new types of
printing from FDM to SLA to SLS and more
and more they're actually bringing us
closer to materials you can look at
Neary's glass printing or
electrospinning clothing or wood
printing or carbon fiber and fiberglass
printing these digital technologies are
not taking us further from reality
they're creating a renewed interest in
physical material properties and we can
see this at a number of different scales
we can look at the smallest of scales
perhaps the at-home DIY maker community
of growing community of people that are
enabled by digital technologies whether
that's 3d printers or digital
fabrication or AR VR or Arduino Zoar
you name it new capabilities that are
creating an interest in questioning how
we make things questioning material
properties inventing new processes to
make and we'll see some of that from
Nadia in a bid you can look at the other
sector of the industrial fabrication and
manufacturing sector and obviously
digital technologies have enabled us to
make things in new ways they've enabled
us to radically rethink material
performance and physical physical
properties but maybe most interesting is
the research sector you can look at
synthetic biology material science bio
printing organ printing and I think all
of these are pointing to the fact that
there's truly a materials revolution
happening enabled by the digital
revolution and it's not that these are
just arguing for the separation of
digital and physical technologies and
now they're coming back together or we
can easily talk between digital and
physical it's literally that the
physical is becoming digital physical
and digital are blending so what I mean
by that is literally we can now program
materials to sense actuate and have
logic in this case the material sensing
light and temperature it can sense
moisture it can sense all sorts of
triggers to become an actuator to fold
curl stretch shrink squirm swim you can
literally embed codes in physical
materials to transform into the letters
MIT or sophisticated and complicated
geometries you can embed programs so
those materials are sensing their
environment responding and then enacting
that program into physical form we can
also embed instructions for materials to
assemble themselves so these can go from
arbitrary structures into furniture we
can go beyond assembly into lifelike
property so they can assemble they can
grow they can encapsulate they can
divide they can grow and divide grow and
divide like cellular mitosis we can show
replication not just in robotic
mechanisms not just in biological
materials but we can show replication
and physical dumb simple materials that
are shaking on a table in a lab I think
all of these demonstrate that physical
materials are not just responding to
digital
properties and not just something that
we make through digital fabrication but
that they have digital properties
embedded in them and we can now program
them just like we did computers and
machines and yesterday we programmed
computers and machines but I believe
today we're programming matter itself so
that's exactly what this panel is about
this panel is called programmable
because we're really rethinking
programmable from software and how we
are interfacing the programmable
technology to digital fabrication to
embedding programs literally in
materials and thinking about the context
across different disciplines so we have
an amazing line-up of speakers in this
session and I'll introduce them briefly
the first is Ben Frey and Casey Reese
Casey is a professor at UCLA and a
computational artist who co-developed
processing with Ben Frey while they were
at the Media Lab processing is an
open-source programming language and a
sketchbook sketchbook for the visual
arts Ben Frey is the principal fathom
here in Boston and best known for his
work in data visualization and
information design next we'll have Manu
Prakash Manu is an assistant professor
of bioengineering at Stanford Manu is a
scientist and physicist working at the
intersection of physical biology and
computing and he's best known for his
work on bubble logic water computing in
the folda scope dollar microscope that
can be folded from paper
Benjamin Bratton is a professor of
visual arts and the director of the
Center of design and geopolitics at UC
San Diego
benjamin is an architect and design
theorist best known for his theories on
global computation and algorithmic
governance and Nadia Peake is a
postdoctoral researcher at MIT Center
for bits and atoms and Nadia is best
known for her work on machines that make
machines and object-oriented Hardware
last but not least our moderator for
this session is Kevin Slavin Kevin is an
assistant professor of media arts and
sciences and the head of the playful
systems group at the MIT Media Lab and
with that I'll hand it over to Kevin
thanks so much
you